we have to talk about something really
important today
uh and the reason that this is so
important is that we can't
solve problems unless we understand them
and over the last few days as different
folks have weighed in
on the violent trumpist insurrection
that took place last week
i've seen more and more commentaries
that are missing the boat when it comes
to the immediate and proximate causes
of the insurrection and of the coup
attempt and specifically i'm talking
about
claims that ultimately what happened
last week
comes down to merely economic unfairness
and inequality and anger by the
so-called working class
and even lots of people that i greatly
respect have weighed in on this
issue and i believe they are wrong i'll
give you an example
with total peace and love my former
economics professor from the university
of massachusetts
economist richard wolff tweeted quote
what was seen in the capitol building of
washington on january 6
was another manifestation of angry
working-class people
this will only continue unless basic
changes happen in this country
we need to do something about the
inequality of this society
i love richard wolff he's been a guest
on this show a dozen times i was
recently on his show
this is the worst take i've ever seen
from richard wolff who typically has
really great takes to some degree
this idea is a version of class
reductionism class reductionism
is the idea that in the end all
oppressions strife
violence unrest it all comes down merely
to class struggle
and racial struggle is really class
struggle
and nationalistic struggle is really
class struggle etc it's a gender
struggle is really class struggle
and that if we reduce inequality it's
going to solve all of these different
problems
and i think we have to be very careful
because
nobody's claiming that economics and
class struggle
uh are are not important in in
just about everything that we see in our
political system
and even those claiming that it played a
role last week
are right but in this particular case
the class struggle aspect of this absent
a more detailed and comprehensive
analysis falls
woefully short in explaining what
happened last week remember
shortly after donald trump was elected
there was a whole bunch of talk about
this was about economic anxiety economic
anxiety motivated people to give donald
trump a shot because he spoke
to those economic anxieties and to some
degree
it's true in that donald trump as a
faux populist right-wing populist that
rhetoric
certainly appeals to economic anxiety in
many people
but then as we had more information
about the motivations of trump voters
we came to learn that while there was
economic anxiety
on both the left and the right that the
right was motivated to vote for donald
trump by many other things
including the resonance of donald
trump's xenophobia
fear of losing perceived or actual
status
to immigrants coming in and taking jobs
two brown people
s whole countries that entire narrative
and case in point
there are so many counterpoints to the
class reductionist argument
or explanation about last week riots
that
the explanation of this is merely class
struggle
would be dangerous to accept as a full
explanation for what we saw
including by the way that many of the
people
that participated in the insurrection
they had the money to not only
travel to washington dc but to stay in
hotels that aren't cheap now i know that
there were groups funding the travel
but many many for many people that
wasn't the case these people were able
to afford going to dc taking time off
from work
if they have a job if they need to work
and staying in expensive hotels
and so there are uh uh so that's one
aspect the other aspect is
there are tons of people on the left and
right
that economically are way worse off than
the protesters rioters last week
but they were not there and there are
even examples of wealthy people
going to dc on private jets to
participate in the riot although that's
anecdotal obviously most of these
rioters
did not fly in on private jets but the
point here
is that there is something unique to
those who yes
mostly are not particularly privileged
economically
but there is a significant xenophobic
component
there is a significant ignorance to
reality component
people who fall for listen if this was
just economic anxiety
you wouldn't see that the people at the
riot are the people who
fell for the obvious lies from trump
about a stolen election
what was really the most common factor
among the rioters
was that they fell for and they believed
that the election was stolen from donald
trump which is demonstrably untrue
there were rich and poor people who fell
for that there were elites and
non-elites who fell for that and
importantly poor people
who didn't fall for it weren't their
rioting people who were significantly
more
economically disadvantaged or oppressed
by the economic system
weren't there rioting because they
didn't believe this stupid narrative
that the election was stolen
and so i very much appreciate the class
aspect
that at a general level has generated
anxiety and a desire for change
the people that participated in this
riot exposed
the trump movement for what it really is
and it's not merely an economic anxiety
movement
it's a particularly extreme radical
conspiratorial worldview
informed by being uninformed that sure
to some degree
overlaps with aspects of economic
anxiety but the truth is that at this
point
economic anxiety is a reality for a huge
portion of this country
that there i agree with richard wolff
and others when half the country can't
meet
an unexpected 400 expense without going
into debt
just about any group unless you're
saying we're only serving
private jet owners just about any group
health care workers
factory workers educational workers
whoever all of these groups will include
a lot of economic anxiety but that
doesn't mean that that's the cause of
violent radical insurrectionist violence
and let's not miss the forest for the
trees and pretend that it goes away
simply by solving economic inequality um
you listen you'll solve economic
inequality
and a lot of these people will be
furious that now
uh they are on the same level as a lot
of people that they don't deserve
they don't believe deserve believe to be
economically stable and that gets us
back to the xenophobia
and and the rest of it so i i think that
these analyses miss the mark i've seen a
bunch of them
and i'm curious to hear your thoughts
you can find me on twitter
at deepakman i want to take a second to
tell you about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol
wipes no touch infrared thermometers and
all of their prices
are very reasonable i also love snh
masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over a hundred and
fifty dollars you can get there by going
to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save twenty percent on
everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david